Mày giờ, các đần vị trình mô đã có mặt tại thực niệm ở để trình khai giếm vụ khá xát,
thăm giò các vị trí, khu bực nghi ngờ là có chôn cất hả cô để xế, khu bực tình kép độ tiên là khu bực xuống một.
Các dễ tích khoảng tám chăm mệt vong, được lượng công bình tình hạnh sử dụng các thích vị trình dụng,
có những vụ kép cha giò gỡ các thích vị bật lượng nổ, tại những vị trí khu bực đá xát lệng.
Sau khi kẹn chà, sự lý sông thì bản giáu lại cho khu bực của được lượng khá xát thăm giò.
Nhưng viên bản đầu có những vụ chắc kíu, sắc định vị trí tỏ đầu trên bản đầu với vị trí tự nhiệm,
bảo đam chi ra, phục vụ như vụ khá xát thăm giò thì kiếm.
Thăm giò sẽ trải thăm giò khá xát nhóm nghiên kíu thuộc nhận hảo qua học tự nhiên,
tại hảo cú ra thành vô chỉ mình đã sử dụng 2 phức pháp thăm giò cũng đã đà xuyên lắm đất và anh biết.
Thêm nóng nghiên kíu đã đà xuyên đất sẽ phát xóm định từ xúc mặt đất,
nếu gặp một số gì bật dị thường sẽ phản xa chờ lại.
Mày đò sẽ thù đận được chiến tín hiểu những lắt cắt từ xóm định từ để phân tích
tìm ra những vị trí có gì thường.
Từ dưới léo thu tập đồ thì nóng nghiên kíu sẽ xây dựng gắc bản đầu không giản bà chờ,
để từ đó tìm ra những vị trí có dạng sau phó xuống để phục vụ cho công tắc xa định vị trí
chính xác của vực có một lịch sĩ.
Công tắc thăm giò khá xát xác được chình kai ngay trong các ngày từ mấy lắm đến mấy tạng tằng sau.
Bộ tư lạnh thành vô chỉ mình đã mời các chuyên ra,
nhưng chúng cùng thăm già hỗ trợ từ lượng,
thông tin cho quá trình từ kiện nhìn buồn khá xát, thăm giò tiếp kiếm.